there was a witch doctor who had laid
this child down
and put herbs all around her body and
was about to cut her
before the security guard
found her and rescued her and brought
her to this baby's home where i was
working
[Music]
i knew quite early on that i wanted to
work in television
i wanted to be a video editor i realized
that in my teens
and i put everything i possibly could
into making
that happen i've worked on love island
i'm a celebrity
get me out of here strictly come dancing
x factor
the voice made in chelsea uh
what else too hot to handle um
and four in a bed which is possibly one
of my favorite shows
what was it that inspired you to go from
being a video editor to leaving that
kind of pie
as much as i enjoyed my job i felt just
a little disillusioned by it and felt
that i needed
a bit of a shake-up and a friend of mine
suggested that i contact
a british lady who set up an ngo
in uganda that looked after abandoned
babies
periodically she needed media volunteers
to go over and make
films for change and i just thought yeah
why not
so i got in touch with her and the next
thing i knew
like two months later i found myself on
a plane
to kampala uganda
it kampala can seem really kind of
glitzy and cosmic
cosmopolitan and fun but you scratch the
surface
and there is there is a lot of sadness
there and a lot of that comes from
poverty
one of the ngo representatives was
telling me about
some of the children in the baby's home
where i'd be working
and she told me about this little girl
who had survived child sacrifice
and i was like
what you know i i'm part nigerian
um you know so i've heard about
witchcraft and juju and witch doctors
and
you know my grandfather was a
traditional healer so i've grown up
hearing about the occult
but never had i heard of child sacrifice
the very first day i sought her out and
she was a shadow she would cower in the
corner of the room
not look at anybody visibly scarred and
and just truly traumatized she was
found she was found on a construction
site
by a security guard there was a witch
doctor who had laid this child down
and put herbs all around her body and
was about to cut her
before the security guard
found her and rescued her and brought
her to this baby's home where i was
working
and she'd been there about six months
before before i arrived
sorry it's okay
she's really special to me yeah
so i'd heard about this practice then
met this girl
fallen head over heels in love with her
and
researched i wanted to know what there
was to know
about it so i read articles i spoke to
people
i spoke to locals and very quickly
recognized that this was a this was a
real problem this was prevalent
in uganda and there was always somebody
who knew someone who had
had their child sacrificed or you know
it was very much
a taboo subject but people
were aware of it happening
why do people do child sacrifices what
is the reason for that
there is a widespread belief in not just
uganda
that when you sacrifice a child it will
lead to
riches to prosperity power
so people will
visit a witch doctor with an issue
and
depending on what the issue is the witch
doctor will say okay
you go and bring me the head of a child
you go and bring me the genitals of a
boy
you go and bring me the tongue of a girl
and you'll have what you need
you spoke to other survivors can you
give us another survivor story
so there was one boy who
who had been lured out
by his uncle to go in
uh to go and buy some soap
on the way they had picked up this
little boy's twin brother
so the two of them uh went off to buy
soap with their uncle
and the uncle led them into a bush
and and
cut off the head of one of the twin boys
while the other one watched and then
removed his genitals
and left him in a pool of his own blood
and the other boy ran away and was able
to
explain what happened to his family
um yeah
and uh the uncle
was burnt alive by the mob justice
there was not an opportunity for it to
go to trial because of that
often the children are they're
sacrificed when they're conscious when
they're alive they're not given
chloroform they're not knocked over
their head they are conscious and they
feel everything
it's not quick um it's incredibly
painful
and this boy watched his brother go
through that
and that is one of many many many
stories that i've heard
like that i thought i had a duty to
do everything in my power i just felt
like i had no other choice and this was
something that in a heartbeat i wanted
to dedicate the rest of my life to
to stopping and
you know i feel that passions they
choose you
i think to a certain extent i think it
was a
physical emotional um
kind of kinship that i had with this
subject and
i think anybody in my shoes would have
done exactly the same
you know i was absolutely dogged about
this and
i was stunned to the core that this was
happening and
i was willing to do anything and
everything in my power to help these
children and to ensure that they had
a bright future to grow up in
and i met the deputy speaker who
you know said look if you're interested
you know we do have gaps in legislation
and we could probably benefit from you
know specific legislation you know but
it's going to cost money it's going to
you know take a lot of time and barbara
and i was just like yep yep yep yep yep
sign me up
i'm i'm your i'm your woman so i had no
real
understanding of what i was doing but i
knew what the milestones were
you know it's to find a legislator
finish
you know have a draft of a bill present
it to the speaker and then they find an
mp to present the bill and
you know the journey probably begins
there why did you have to introduce the
bill was child sacrifice not illegal at
this point
so obviously it's it's illegal to
sacrifice a child but
defendants were tried under the penal
code um
or other such laws which didn't carry um
particularly strong sentences there was
no definition
of child sacrifice you know so
you know cases where a child was
abducted and for example kept in a
shrine
and gradually sacrificed that's a that's
a case i have heard of
they would be they would be charged with
kidnap and torture which would not carry
the
the an adequate sentence i
spent the next or seven years actually
going back and forth so i would go back
to london earn enough money
then fly back out to uganda mobilize mps
let them know that there is a private
bill that is going to be introduced
are you interested in supporting this
and very very slowly i built up a team
and a network
of people who would then you know
later uh come to support me on
parliament floor
when this bill was introduced but there
were a point where you felt like
giving up
yes um
yeah um often you know i there there are
challenges when it comes to
something like this introducing
something like this i was
very much alone for the first part of
this journey
and child sacrifice is a nasty business
more than once i've been threatened
i've been told that if i continue
terrible things will happen
there will be consequences i've had
people turn up to my house asking where
i
was you know so i was scared
a lot of the time but i think
i i made a pact with myself that
their lives are worth more than mine
and that this was something that i'd
pledged to stop no matter what
stop as much as i could
to giving up i thought about it but
realized that i
i physically i couldn't
i didn't want to think about whether or
not this bill would pass
but it was the timing of it
you know like we were just approaching
the the end of the 10th parliament in
uganda
and this was the tuesday and
if the bill hadn't passed by the friday
we'd have had to start all over again
and that would have meant another not
seven years but at least another two
three years i would have had it in me
but it would have felt like a real
struggle
um so we passed it in record time and
i just remember
we were told that it was unlikely to
pass that day
and we knew if it was going to pass it
was going to be that week
but i remember getting a call on the
tuesday on the fourth
of may 2021 um from my
you know uh colleague in parliament and
this is at 10 o'clock and i was sitting
on my sofa in my pyjamas thinking i've
got a day off
and he was like annie we were presenting
the bill
at half past 10 and i looked my watch
and it was 10 o'clock and i was like
can i swear what the [ __ ] got on a boda
boda which is like a motorcycle taxi
was calling people on the way calling
the mp couldn't get hold of anybody
and i said to the driver i was just like
you need to leg
we need to be there in record time it's
like a half an hour journey we got there
in 10 minutes
i got there with about two minutes to
spare
um you know it was meant to be i was
meant to be there
and i'm just so thrilled that i was and
uh i sat there shaking
uh for i don't know two hours and
yeah and um tonight i don't know how to
put into words what i felt when it
passed really
i couldn't believe it i looked at my
colleague the same one who who called me
at 10 o'clock saying that the bill was
going to be read
and he just looked at me and he was like
it
it just passed
and i just i lost it i completely
lost it
you know something that i had been along
with it
my team fighting for for
seven years it happened
i will never forget that feeling
in a weird way i miss it i miss having a
purpose
like it's like 80 percent pride and
relief and
joy and all of that but you know
i grew up with this bill you know i
became a woman
working on this and it was a huge huge
part of me
and it was gone like that so in a weird
i know that sounds messed up but
um there was sadness weirdly attached to
that
because my baby it you know
it had grown it had grown up and
was doing what it was meant to do
and i just think
[Music]
i never growing up felt that i was
capable really of doing
that much or having that much of an
impact on the world and
in that moment i just
felt like i was enough
and that's something that i along with
the people that i work with had done
had really made a difference in the
world and had
saved the lives of so many vulnerable
children
and i'm just so proud of it
[Music]
that's
[Music]
and i remember unlocking my phone and
what's up was on and i kind of
closed what's up and clicked on the
camera and the second i clicked the film
i saw what i guess the whole world saw